Iran's military said overnight it has
not lost any drones after President
Trump said a u.s. warship destroyed his
word an Iranian drone in a defensive
action this comes as the top US military
commander for the Middle East general
Frank Mackenzie is traveling in the
region and our David Martin is the only
TV correspondent with him Mackenzie was
in Saudi Arabia to build support for a
force to protect vital oil shipments
David Martin reports from Jeddah
Pentagon says the USS boxer took
defensive action when an Iranian drone
came within 1,000 yards the boxer is an
amphibious assault ship part of a fleet
deployed to the Persian Gulf to patrol
shipping orders the u.s. accuses Iran of
interfering with an accusation president
Trump repeated when he announced the
drone had been brought down this is the
latest of many provocative and hostile
actions by Iran against vessels
operating in international waters the
downing came less than a month after
Iran shot down an American drones
prompting the u.s. to prepare a
retaliatory strike which President Trump
called off at the 11th hour u.s. says it
has compelling evidence Iran is behind
the sabotage and harassment of tankers
passing in and out of the Strait of
Hormuz and most recently Iran allegedly
hijacked a small coastal banker claiming
it was smuggling oil illegally on
Thursday we flew with general Frank
McKenzie the top US commander for the
Middle East into Saudi Arabia McKenzie
is in the region working to organize a
flotilla of warships to escort tankers
in and out of the Gulf but not unless
other countries participate that is an
international responsibility not a
United States responsibility but the
United States is very happy to be part
of the solution but only the US can
provide the airpower to defend against
the
attack the Pentagon is reportedly
sending 500 troops to an airbase in
Saudi Arabia last use during the first
Gulf War now nearly 30 years later there
is the possibility of another war this
time against Iran for CBS this morning
David Martin in Jeddah Saudi Arabia